[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream one one
zero edition we are broadcasting from
separate rooms though we know this is
not likely to contain this particular
pathogen but here we are
um
heather can you hear me
i can excellent i can hear you
so i think we're ready to engage you
know questions and maybe we'll come up
with i don't know some answers
we get a lot of great questions this
week i think uh there is some some
pent-up questioning
that can happen from the missing weeks
but first the discord question for the
week is
i am going to be providing testimony at
the state senate sometime within the
next three weeks in defense of women's
rights to sex segregated sports do you
have any advice
yeah
i think way too much way more than we
have time for here right
um
i think the fundamental question is
sports are segregated for a reason that
everybody knew until yesterday to use
douglas murray's formulation
right men and women are on average
different
if women
and men compete together
women lose
there are sports in which men and women
co-ed games are are functional
but an all-male team against an
all-female team the male team wins
that's what title ix is about in the u.s
right
what has happened is a conflation of sex
with gender
gender how it is that you you feel you
should present what it is you know which
of the sort of traditional or
stereotypical roles
that you are drawn to whether or not
it's building things and doing math or
um easing people's problems by spending
long hours talking with them
has more to do with gender than with sex
gender follows from sex but it's not the
same thing
so no one ever thought that there should
be gender segregated sports that doesn't
mean anything and it doesn't make any
sense in part because
apparently you are the gender you say
you are
so sex is biological and real and
immutable in mammals and
we have a long history of reasons
um both legal and evolutionary that are
established
that by which we know that sex
sex-segregated sports is the way that
women end up being allowed to compete on
an even even playing field
once you start allowing people to
declare themselves female and confuse
gender with sex you obliterate the
the protections that women have and you
therefore have destroyed women's sports
yeah i would just add there's something
so odd about the idea that anybody
expects us to explain this and that the
implication is that if we can explain it
clearly enough then we will win but the
fact that we have failed to explain it
clearly is the reason that they are
desegregating sports in this crazy way
and the answer is no everybody
understands this and those who claim not
to understand this are pretending so
where does their indifference to the
rights of women come from yeah
there it is
good that's a good line
all right first question from today from
darkwaresubmissions.com
hello from canada
i'm sure you're aware of the insanity we
are going through i feel like canada is
one of the test territories for the
global plan am i just paranoid am i
losing it do you still think there's a
way out of this thank you so much from
the you guys are punk rock guy which you
are
yeah there
there are ways out of this
we are going to have to stand up we're
going to have to rise up against
these officials who whatever the
explanation are completely botching the
response to the pandemic and they are
putting us in a great deal of danger and
not just us but our children
and
yeah canada
is ahead of the us
australia appears to be ahead of the us
in terms of the tyrannical nonsense
and
you know the the us has not yet played
its role in becoming part of the
resistance but really it's all tied up
in there
i think the
the fundamental difference between this
and
uh prior outbreaks of tyranny is that
because this one's global in some sense
the resistance movement has to be as
well and uh anyway don't give up hope
yes
we are we are going to find ourselves
in battle and it's one that we have to
win
yeah that's right that's right
an animal rescue in kabul has reached 70
percent of a fundraising goal to fly 300
animals to safety in vancouver
the effort is virtually stalled the last
few days
social media is the only communication
channel between the rescue and its
supporters
any advice on applying game theory
strategy knowledge of human behavior or
other means to break out of the echo
chamber and jump start this
time-sensitive mission
boy i wish i
knew more of what this was about i mean
yeah i agree this this struck me is so
surprising and so out of
out of any context that i'm familiar
with
that i have a hard time knowing how to
respond on this one yeah i mean if if
the animals that are being rescued
you know it really depends if they're
dogs then i would say you want to play
that up because uh
people love their dogs if they're
i don't know
sand fleas then probably won't work and
if they're armadillo i don't know
um
i don't think i mean i i may be i may be
excuse me behind in my biogeography but
i don't think there are any armadillos
in afghanistan yeah i'm not actually
sure if there are or there aren't my
real point was without knowing what kind
of animals are being rescued and
from what it's hard to say how
one might
jump start the effort uh but
presumably there's some reason that
people are going through the effort of
rescuing animals and moving them half a
world away and
yeah i i wish i had anything to give you
in terms of game theory but really the
question is one of human psychology it
sounds like and
uh probably figuring out what the
motivation is and how to tap into it so
that people
are captivated by the story
yeah i think that's right um
total coincidence but while we were
trying to answer that question
fairfax and tesla were getting into it
on the floor here i don't know if you
could hear the growling and the
uh and the
the cat noises but if you could that was
not the animals not being oh boy not
being
rescued from afghanistan but uh our two
cats going at it
it was the ongoing case of spy versus
spy that we
have in our environment
yes exactly
uh okay
so sorry sorry for a really inadequate
answer on that question which i knew we
would give because i just i don't know
enough about what to say there
um
here we have
two
quotes from c.s lewis
with a link to the full essay
two different links two different
quotations from c.s lewis
for if ow now he's going after my toes
stop that
um
okay
for if crime and disease are to be
regarded as the same thing it follows
that any state of mind which our masters
choose to call disease can be treated as
crime and compulsorily cured
it will be vain to plead that states of
mind which displease government need not
always involve moral turpitude and do
not therefore always deserve forfeiture
of liberty
that's one great
and
second again from c.s lewis this very
kindness stings with intolerable insult
to be cured against one's will and
curative states which we may not regard
as disease is to be put on a level of
those who have not yet reached the age
of reason or those who never will to be
classed with infants imbeciles and
domestic animals
they certainly are
infantilizing us
and or
we are allowing our infantilization
and
um
i would say they are
infantilizing us
they are gaslighting us
they are
intimidating us and that different
things work on different people
but that at some level
they will do whatever it takes to make
sure that we are denied
all choice
that we are left with one option and
that we are
unpersoned should we find that
unacceptable
and
i think the thing is anybody who does
that is obviously
the definition of the wrong side of
history we know that these people are
bad however they became that way because
of their insistence on robbing us of all
all options
all agency
um and and all reason and you know how
much do you need to know about
uh
people like that before you realize
actually i'm not listening to them
anymore i'm with the people who are
making sense
how do we explain i i don't think this
is a non-sequitur although it may sound
like it and you and i have not discussed
this at all actually it hasn't come up
between us yet
how do you explain the number of just
blatant inaccuracies
um from scotus in the position of the
the
possible mandates the supreme court of
the united states specifically i think
kagan and sotomayor
um
had some just whoppers in there and i
and
i didn't watch very much and i didn't
see that many transcripts either but my
sense is i may be wrong um that they
believe what they're saying yeah oh boy
they
they really believe what they're saying
and
wow like what then what do we what do we
do
well i think
i mean i really think it comes down to
this you know you called them whoppers
we might call them whoppers
from wapo
uh from the washington post you know and
i think i think the thing is look
let's
let's be kind
to our supreme court justices these
people
live in a very visible position at the
head of officialdom
and
those in officialdom
for reasons that we would have to guess
that probably can't afford
to
entertain things that they are being
told
are
fringe and
misinformation or disinformation
dangerous
and so i think the point is if you're
spooked enough because your position
does not allow you to engage these
things
you reject them every time they show up
on a screen and you basically are
constantly reasserting that you are not
from
the crazy
tribe nor do you listen to them and if
that's your bent because your job
demands it
then
what we're talking about is like a
foreign language and so in some sense
this was like a
an exploration
of
the party-line mind right people who
have never trafficked in doubt about the
public health authorities and are
therefore effectively
reverse engineering what must be behind
their proclamations but i guess so this
i've already been surprised and stunned
and beyond disappointed by a lot of
people these last two years
who
can question stories when they come
in a domain that they have at least
passing familiarity with
and we have long noticed and talked
about on dark horse but for decades have
noticed
how
much more easily people would put faith
in a proclamation it becomes numbers
or it comes with an imprimatur of a
scientific authority because most people
are so badly educated in math and in
science in school that they have long
since said that i black box that i have
to choose the people i listen to
and if if they think that the
current government is one that is
uh you know legitimately working on
their behalf then they will look to the
authorities the government has appointed
that's devastating and is doing
tremendous damage across
across media let's let's say
it is precisely the job of the supreme
court of the united states
to
have doubt on every subject
i i feel like you know i don't i am
i am no legal scholar in any way but i
feel like that is actually
a reasonable claim to being one of their
top
priorities
yeah but
i mean i i think you're on the right
track here
everybody is being
bullied away from their professional
responsibilities
right we are firing doctors and nurses
who as doctors and nurses are not
compelled that these vaccines are
safe and effective enough to take right
we are
intimidating doctors who talk about
alternative treatments that they have
tried and have gotten value from
so the point is everybody you and i are
supposed to not do what you and i do
right we're trained to look into complex
systems and to understand them even in
light of imperfect evidence that's what
evolutionary biologists do we we never
have randomized controlled trials we're
always dealing with data sets that are
confusing and imperfect and deeply
incomplete
and so
you know we're not supposed to be doing
that now why because this is that kind
of emergency
well what i don't remember
is the discussion that says where is the
threshold right
we all agree that there are
circumstances so dangerous
that your normal instincts should be put
on hold right we all agree with that
right if the ship is sinking
then that is the priority what we have
not discussed is
okay at least the initial variants of
sars cov2
were worse than the flu
how much worse than the flu does
something have to be
before you turn
society upside down before you allow
small businesses to be destroyed and all
of that wealth transferred to their
gigantic competitors how bad does
something have to be before we suspend
normal and the answer is we pass stuff
around all the time in a normal year
people are passing flu to each other
grandmothers are dying because somebody
gets on a plane you shouldn't right this
happens all the time
now maybe the point is we should have a
very different approach to all
infectious disease and it should affect
travel but we've never had that
conversation that we were just simply
told that this pathogen was above some
threshold where we needed to turn the
world upside down and effectively to do
it indefinitely until when
we don't know they've never told us who
are we apparently that's not ours to
know and so
you've got supreme court justices
not behaving like supreme court justices
you've got members of congress not
behaving like members of congress you've
got presidents not behaving like
presidents you've got professors not
behaving like professors you've got
philosophers not doing philosophy right
everybody is failing in their
professional responsibilities because
something is forcing them out of it and
those of us who have attempted to
continue to do what we do have found
ourselves in
this weird
nether world where
we are portrayed as the enemies of
reason and decency and health and you
know okay that's why right you're in a
world where the doctors who are doing
the doctoring are now heretics and the
professors who are continuing to try to
do the job of sorting stuff out are you
know
dangerous conspiracy theorists or
whatever and the answer is look either
you're smart enough to see through that
and to say wait a second maybe those are
the doctors i should be listening to
or you're not and
i guess i'm not terribly surprised that
the supreme court
is
staffed by people who have not figured
their way out of the matrix because they
live at the center of it
yeah
i think you're right
it doesn't um
it doesn't breed confidence though does
it oh boy no it don't terrify us
but you know it's also i think many
people are sort of groping for you know
they're
asking well
what will end this
right
how is this going to end if this is
where we are and the answer is
it's not going to be easy but so many
things come down to the same calculation
that a smoker ought
to have right the fact that what you
face to quit smoking is very very
difficult is no argument whatsoever to
not quit smoking it's an argument to do
it now because it's only going to get
worse
so that's where we are the point is
what's going to end this
well
it's going to be us finally facing it
together and saying no right that's
what's going to end it when would be a
good time to do that uh i'm trying to
remember what the aphorism is
something like uh the best time
to do it would have been two years ago
the second best time is now right
yep it's that yeah that's right
this is uh in keeping next question
the situation is deteriorating fast in
canada is it futile to think we can
still live our lives without being
vaccinated what will it take to break
the fear spell thank you both very much
we missed you
well i i
at one level the fact the vaccines
aren't doing any of the things they were
supposed to do at some point should get
noticed by someone but it doesn't seem
to be getting noticed no but it's worse
it's worse right the the evidence is
actually mounting that these vaccines
make you more likely to contract the
disease the idea that that has not
caused our governments to say wait a
second hold on with the vaccines
something has changed let us figure out
what it is we'll be back to you in a
minute right that's what a rational
government would do the fact that it was
like nope hey the advice we gave you
just so happens to still be the right
advice in fact
even though in fact it's obviously
upside down
that tells you whoa i can't afford to
listen to that person if that person
tells me to ingest something i ought to
wonder if it's a poison right yeah so
i would you know can you continue to
live unvaccinated
look i'm not advising you to do anything
but i would say your government
has betrayed you and it has failed to do
what it promised it could do if you
think that that failure is on people who
have not complied then look into
gibraltar
right the fact is their one remedy does
not work so in light of that
can you afford to take their advice and
just grin and bear it how many times
will they force you to be boosted
right they are exposing it to danger
each time they do that so
in some sense as appalling as what is
going to happen to you if you resist is
how appalling is what's going to happen
to you if you don't resist you don't
know it could be ten years from now that
you find out the answer to that question
so i would just your feet then die on
your knees yeah exactly
uh exactly
you want you want to repeat that i think
it broke up with skype
oh better it's better to live on your
feet than to die on your knees this from
the old man in the [ __ ] house in catch
22 an excerpt that we read from
some weeks ago
yep it's it's the right answer and um
you know i i don't think i owe anybody
an apology but i feel like offering one
i'm sorry it's that stark right i'm
sorry that that's where we are in
history and that that means that you
have to make some awful choice but
that's the nature of history
all right
you ready yep so when i'm looking at the
questions i can't see you and i can
never see the screen that other people
are seeing so but you remember what i
look like
well now i do okay
while cloth masks might not be as
effective as n95s could they still help
train the immune system by allowing a
manageable amount of virus through
not unlike playing in dirt as a child
versus being totally sanitized
i've wondered this
but of course it might also concentrate
stuff on the other side of the mask like
if you are sick you might get sicker
yeah or i would do that even more so
well might not be worse the concern
is so first of all the masks seem to be
better if you put them on the sick
rather than try to protect the well
but if you use something like a cloth
mask
and mind you i will say again cloth
masks are something i got wrong at the
beginning of this right i think the
whole story of you and me heather and
what we've been doing is that we started
out with a model that was crude because
our information was bad and our model
got better as our information got better
and as we puzzled through it and that's
why people tuned in masks is something i
got wrong at the beginning and then
came to understand that the evidence
didn't support it and there's even a an
argument that cloth masks could be more
harmful than beneficial
on the basis that a sick person with a
cloth mask might find that the droplets
which would ordinarily fall to the floor
are broken up by effectively the mesh
of the cloth and they find themselves
much lighter and they make it farther
into the world so
yes your hypothesis that there could be
a mechanism whereby cloth masks expose
you to just enough that might well be
right or it might well make things worse
and the answer is we don't have evidence
that says anything
other than cloth masks are inadequate to
prevent people from contracting the
disease which
is not an answer to your question but i
think the answer is a lot of things are
possible it would be great to know in
in detail but we don't know
yep
canadian here
should i get out
if so how is the united states treatment
of autistic children
perhaps asking the crowd is florida
suitable
for um
kids on the autism spectrum
i don't know anything about
how florida is
for kids
i also don't know anything about how the
us is compared to other countries i um
i've had friends who have done clinical
work with autistic kids and i think um
like with so much i mean probably every
system ever
but certainly in the united states in
healthcare
the care that you will get is dependent
entirely on circumstance and uh in part
that circumstance is just luck in part
it's money and access and who you know
and in part it's luck
and
the fact that we seem to know very
little about um what we should be doing
for people across all of these medical
domains means that um what's considered
the best may not be the best anyway so
it may just add that to your model as
well but
i have no knowledge about florida
compared to the other states um i will
say there seems to be some very
some some
some good treatment for some people on
the autism spectrum
um
in the united states but again highly
patchy yes and i will just say having
nothing to do with the autism
the very fact of our for-profit health
care system
i have been persuaded
uh
by dr roligator
among others that single-payer actually
opens up the prospect of medical
authoritarianism in a way that a
for-profit
system built around choice does not
that said a
single-payer system at least probably i
don't know whether it covers autism i
presume that it does and if it does
that's a big step down that you would
face in
coming to uh to florida
yeah
that's right
uh sorry i'm just looking through
questions now we got a bunch more came
in um
oh i don't know the answer to this but
since you recently said it can you point
me to some evidence that vaccinated
people are more likely than unvaccinated
to get omicron so far i'm following dr
malone's feed love you both
um that is a good question i've seen
several things one led to a very
confusing paper which i'm still
uh slogging my way through so i don't
have i don't have the the goods to
deliver
but i think hey i should say the
evidence on this is changing rapidly and
it seems to be headed in that direction
but b even the evidence we have is a
little bit hard to parse so i'm working
on getting something to point to but i
don't have it
okay
uh it's
not exactly a similar type of question
but um
okay
next we'll get to the this other one
that just made me laugh
um potential ovarian damage from the
vaccine isn't studied or discussed like
myocarditis is this true
um
could you repeat it i didn't quite catch
it i just hit yes and i don't have any
memory of how to get back to rubbing
yes
what kind of damage was it ovarian
damage as opposed to myocarditis i will
say and again i can't share my screen
here but i have this paper that just
came out um by edelman at all
in obstetrics and gynecology is the name
of the journal
called association between menstrual
cycle length and coronavirus disease
2019 vaccination
a us cohort
um
and what they find
is
some effect but not very much now
there's a lot of caveats
um i don't it's i have not i've not
i've skimmed the paper and read parts of
it but i haven't really um
fully
internalized it i'm trying to remember
the people they were looking at for this
uh were people who are using an app to
track their cycle so women who were
using in this natural cycles app
to
voluntarily prospectively track
physiologic data related to their
menstrual cycles for purposes of
non-hormonal pregnancy prevention or
planning
so this is um that that's the cohort
that we're looking looking at here in
this paper which is going to be a fairly
highly educated um probably fairly
wealthy cohort of people who are um
using an app
um to
either for contraception or for um or
for pregnancy um to track hormonal stuff
but the the main conclusion of the paper
is and i quote
overall the vaccinated cohort
experienced a less than one day
unadjusted increase in the length of
their menstrual cycle during their first
vaccine cycle compared with their three
pre-vaccination cycles
so
um longer but not by much
that said what i think is hiding here i
think the devil in the details here
is that um
most people didn't have any effect at
all
and some people had pretty strong
effects and this is going to be the
place where we you know we keep on
getting lied to you with statistics
throughout this thing
and one of the easiest ways to lie to
people is to use a mean when you really
should be talking about um you know okay
it's it's
making up numbers here 10 of people who
had rather dramatic effects and 90 of
people had no effect 10 is a huge number
if if it was that right and so just
talking about uh and and they say
somewhere in this paper and i don't have
it highlighted so i can't find it um
that
that
that less than that one day difference
in menstrual cycles among the vaccinated
versus among the vaccinated compared to
their pre-vaccinated state compared to
among the unvaccinated compared to the
same time period
uh is very small but it's probably
so small because so many people had no
effect at all and that many of the
people who had an effect had a larger
effect so this is beginning to be
consistent with a lot of what we're
hearing that you know maybe it's about
the batches
maybe it's about some people being
particularly susceptible to the lipid
nanoparticles who knows could be about
where in the cycle actually well there
is actually some evidence here that if
you've got the two shots both within the
same cycle then you tended to have a two
two-day delay so there is that too but
um that to the extent that these
vaccines are not good for you
um that doesn't mean that maybe even the
majority of people who get them don't do
just fine you know just like any of the
toxins that we are exposed to some
people will be just fine and that will
be due to you know vagaries of um
genetics and circumstance and and
everything else could be could be also
uh downstream of the question of the
aspiration of the shot itself something
john campbell explored at length so you
could imagine that if it doesn't hit a
vein for most people and it does hit a
vein for a small number of people and
women for whom it went into a vein then
it's much more likely to find its way to
the ovaries and concentrations that
matter something something like that
right that's what i'm not saying that is
what it is i'm saying it's a hypothesis
about what it might be
i will also say it's not the only line
of evidence here if i'm recalling
correctly
the initial concern
about uh
ovaries came from a study in rodents a
japanese study in which there was a
concentration
in ovaries of i think it was rats yeah
so in any case the point is you've got
multiple lines of evidence saying you've
got an interaction between you know a
and b and that's reason for extreme
caution
um
so anyway that's where we are
exactly
uh
okay
uh
dr hh blink thrice if you need help
i'm doing just fine
we're we're doing just fine we're we're
we're putting on a show here i've talked
to friends about lab leak and vaccines
all this so this is that was the first
part of this question the rest of it is
an actual question i think um i've
talked to friends about lab leak and
vaccines all were convinced that i was
worshiping alec jones i haven't lost
friends yet but it feels lonely do you
see any signs of hope
yeah this bit about um
alex jones wasn't as wrong as they told
us he was is
concerning to a lot of people
yeah um
that's always a question
and it is also true that you know
the magic trick is visible from certain
places
the idea that to oppose
vaccine mandates
to oppose any vaccine to have any doubt
about the efficacy safety the wisdom of
any vaccine renders you an anti-vaxxer
no matter how vaccinated you may be
is
a tell
right that is the monster letting you in
on a secret which is that the term
anti-faxer doesn't mean a goddamn thing
it's a threat right it's a stigma that
will be
appended to you irrespective of your
beliefs and behavior and that you should
be very very frightened and you should
run from that stigma you should do what
they tell you so they don't wield it at
you and the answer is
don't listen to them right if they're
going to define anti-vaxxers so
everybody's an anti-vaxxer well then
fine right then it's a meaningless term
they did the same with racist right it's
the same trick same thing it's the same
and you know we we are the living proof
of this right we were the racists of
evergreen in spite of the fact that we
are the opposite of racists so if you
saw that and you stuck with the story
long enough to figure out that hey
people are screaming about you being
racist but it doesn't seem anything
racist about you and in fact there are
an awful lot of students
of a wide diversity of descriptions who
seem to think that that's a preposterous
claim right if you saw that then you
realize oh racist isn't a description of
something it's a threat right it's a
weapon it's a weapon
and so anyway i mean
i can't remember when we only though see
it again
that doesn't mean it doesn't feel lonely
the person asking the question said
um
yeah just increasingly it's lonely well
it is
and it isn't if you i mean it depending
upon the circumstances of your life it
may be that you don't have
anyone to find but
our experience has been
that there are some people
who have broken the wrong way in each of
these circumstances
and they've been perfectly horrible
and then there have been other people
who've shown up and who have shined and
i would say in no case
has the
replacement of people who have been
awful with people who have been good
been a downgrade in
the number of friends the quality of
friends the decency of those friends in
every case it's been an upgrade and so
the question really is are you
remaining attached to people who had
such weakness of character
that they fell for these tricks
and are you overlooking the possibility
that
there might be new people who
would be much higher quality and much
more rewarding to hang out with and i
you know the the weird caveat of that
well what heather and i have seen
is that our friend group is really
eclectic it cuts across all kinds of
lines right that has been very much to
the good it is a much more interesting
dynamic friend group and yeah it
contains people who have
you know radically other ways of viewing
the world but that's all to the good as
far as we're concerned so
who are you overlooking is the question
who that does have ears to hear
uh are you
failing to see
and what would happen if you uh
if you try to team up with them
well i don't disagree with any of that
but i don't think it um
i doubt that it is perfectly responsive
to the person asking the question
because
it will be obvious
to most people watching us um that
many of the costs that we endure for
being public with our
um with what we do
but
one of the benefits is hidden in the
ants that you just gave which is that
people find us
and um if you're if you're not public if
you know if
your job whether or not you intended it
to be or not
uh isn't to public declare publicly
declare where it is that you stand on
issues then how is it that people would
find you like you know how is it the
person asking the question well we'll
find these people who i know exist who
but whom you are alluding to um but in
this in this way we are this is the this
is one of the
the ways that it's easier
yeah
yeah although
now that i get the question better i do
think that there is uh an answer
in that
right
you and i also find that with people and
you know most people don't know who we
are um so we have a lot of those
conversations too and if you are bold
about
confessing your doubts and your concerns
and you just
you know you
you take the risk of letting people know
that you're not on board with the
conventional narrative and that actually
you've come to understand some different
things
i believe you will be absolutely shocked
by the
percentage of
your fellow citizens who are also
possessing of doubts afraid to talk and
feeling a bit lonely and you know
go with it
talk talk to people let them know you
know what i don't think this advice
makes any sense and here's why and uh
see what you get back i'll be i'd be
shocked if you didn't find a lot of
kindred spirits
yeah
um
let's see
i don't know where this one is coming
from but i'm just going to read it
rates of domestic abuse are often hard
to measure
but could be as high as 55 to 73 for
lesbian couples according to wikipedia
if true what selective pressures cause
it to be so high
i would be shocked if that was right i
mean why would i know but
that seems really unlikely
yeah no i i agree this question has the
potential to be sort of an amazing one
to spend time with but
i'm reminded of occasionally i would get
a question in class
be like
i just it just doesn't it's just not
worth exploring this premise until we
establish or explain this question until
we establish the premise has any basis
in reality um because i think for you
and for me and this is this is an
interesting part about us being in
different rooms um
we didn't have any we had no shared
communication about this before i read
that aloud to you
but i too had the reaction of like oh
really
i would have thought you know
i would have thought quite not
right so um
rather than do the thing that they the
sort of non-evolutionary biologists
biologists accuse us of doing of like
adaptively arm waving explanations into
existence with a premise that both of us
think isn't true i think we should pass
on this one yeah but if there's evidence
yeah we'd look at it yeah
um ezekiel emanuel and two bioethicists
have written op-eds advocating permanent
digital vaccine passports and treating
all respiratory viruses with lockdowns
plus vastly expanding public health
technocracy
please comment
i haven't read them but i know i know
i knew this had happened
um
and i don't want to i don't want to
vouch for this summary
although this is someone who's written
questions before and and has been
accurate um i do i did see the little
tidbit about advocating permanent
digital vaccine passports i did not see
the bit about treating all respiratory
viruses was it with um yeah lockdowns
um
for [ __ ] sake
well okay a this goes back to what we
were talking about in the main podcast
they have one tool that is legitimate at
their disposal and that is to convince
us that the benefit of this exceeds the
cost which i think would be very hard to
do for one thing
it
suggests
a an obscene and cartoonish
understanding of our control over these
things
right vaccine passports you really think
you'll be able to generate a vaccine for
all of these things and that it's going
to be worth doing the rate at which
these things move through the population
and the amount of time it takes to
actually get a safe vaccine to market
and the amount of time that it takes to
even know that that vaccine is safe
i mean long term maybe you're right
about what what ultimately is part of
this but um as the just a little bit
that i read about this
uh the the digital vaccine passports
thing was responsive to
no paper vaccine passports are not
sufficient paper vaccine cards that you
have to show in some cities to get any
services at all already will not be
sufficient because they're too easily
forged we need something basically where
you know
the
panopticon is here and you you can be
seen and you will be seen in you there
is no escape
yes i was uh actually a a dark horse
episode will be out hopefully sooner
rather than later i was talking to a
very fascinating gentleman from
australia who was talking about
passports that in fact
read your
facial data
and compare it to
your
gps coordinates both of which your phone
is capable of assessing to determine
whether or not you are locked down the
way you are supposed to be
right
right it's an absolutely chilling
combination of technologies and i think
the answer is look we actually i think
i'm in a great position to speak to this
because
before there was covid
i was
troubled
by the casual way that we deal with all
of the viruses that we are
moving around the globe with airplanes
and other kinds of transportation right
we're paying a huge cost for all the
stuff that we are circulating that gets
everywhere right and it's very hard as
an individual to protect yourself from
this without becoming a hermit so what
can we do about that well i think we can
do an awful lot
to track these things what i would do if
i was if it was mine to to say
i would set up an institute to figure
out how these things work right the
purpose of this institute would not be
to adjust anybody's behavior but just to
simply take each path in the pathogen
that shows up and figure out where it
came from how it spreads so that we
could become expert about this rather
than having to guess right then we could
do things that are
incredibly useful right like the amount
of disease we have reduced by getting
people to wash their hands in between
you know when they leave the bathroom
effectively yeah that is tremendously
effective the amount of health that we
have preserved by getting uh sewage
segregated from drinking water right
there are a lot of things the bang for
the buck that you get for very simple
measures can be absolutely huge so
knowing more would be very useful
but i gotta tell you i am not excited
about the idea that these people who
have proved that they can ignore the
most glaring evidence are suddenly going
to be even in even greater charge of our
lives on the basis that they are the
bureaucrats who have been handed that
responsibility no freaking way these
people are not up to the challenge
i don't know if they're you know not
smart enough or just too corrupt you
know it's one or both of those things
but
damn it can't you see they don't know
how to control disease
i'm shocked frankly in this case that
emanuel isn't that um
is in that cohort but there he is
um
it's also true
that a virus to you is not the same
thing as a virus to me as you know as we
are experiencing
presumably you and i have both been
exposed to the same thing
and we have responded differently to it
and uh we all have experiences like this
in our life where
someone gets really sick from some
pathogen and it could only be the same
pathogen and their friend their lover
their mother whatever it is um
has a totally different presentation and
it's not just ones of
scale but also of quality right viruses
affect different people different ways
depending on other true things about
their about their life including how
healthy they are
and whether or not they're vitamin d
deficient and whether or not they're
obese and whether or not they have other
underlying conditions and you know and
how active they are all of these things
and those those public health
interventions that you mentioned
that the us and the rest of the weird
world basically got on board um in
i don't know starting with the
industrial revolution-ish through the
middle of the 20th century
clean drinking water
um
you know we grew up in one of the
polluted cities on earth in la in the
70s but they got their act together you
know clean air to breathe um
got the lead out of the gasoline we have
clean drinking water
and we're putting more and more crap on
our food those of us who can afford to
try to you know try to eat only the food
without all the crap on it but
uh you know we have and and then sewage
sewage treatment right clean drinking
water and not having to run into your
own
deflux
all of these things
help you be healthier so that you can
resist the viruses that are around and
will always be around anyway these are
the things we should be
um maximizing here
and everywhere for public health this
this is what should be happening for
instance in africa not a focus on
vaccines
all right i'm going to add one thing to
this right and you and i have been on
this for
many many months
i don't believe that any public health
authority
who has not pointed out
the hazard of vitamin d deficiency its
role in disease vulnerability and
recommended a course of action in which
individuals can become more robust in
the face of disease i don't believe that
any authority that hasn't done that
is in a position to tell you anything
about your health relative to infectious
disease and yes that goes for you dr
fauci
the fact is
this is the lowest hanging fruit on the
tree and everybody who's looked into it
knows that and for you not to recommend
it is for you to expose people to
needless disease so i don't want to hear
about vaccine passports and i don't want
to hear about digitalization and facial
recognition and you know lockdowns for
colds and
flu until people deal with all of the
easy
safe
low
interference measures that we haven't
done yet right those things come first
before we talk about anything exotic
yep
regarding political polarization what do
you think of a party based strictly and
reflecting best polling data available
reps would have only to do good polling
and vote accordingly
there is a more sophisticated version of
what you're talking about
it is called liquid democracy and there
is a strong argument to be made i will
tell you i've looked at liquid democracy
and the devil is in the details with
respect to structuring it but you could
have a system
in which effectively
a
party ran through an app in which the
constituents were able to
either
voice their opinion on a given issue
which would then
go into the
calculation of the person who had been
elected to the office or more
importantly
they could proxy their
vote
to someone that they believed understood
the matter better
so that is to say you might not know
anything
about climate but you might think james
hansen does know a lot about climate and
so your basic feeling is i'm in no
position to disagree with james hansen
and i trust him so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to proxy my vote in the
liquid democracy party to james hansen
and at any moment that i decide james
hansen isn't the right guy anymore i can
take it back and i can use my vote
directly or i can give it to somebody
else i can proxy it to another authority
right so there is a way that this could
work and it could be
quite good and i will say there's also
an opportunity what you don't i think
don't want
is
in a liquid democracy scenario you don't
want the
um
individual who is elected to the office
to be
effectively a robot right where they are
just simply enacting the will of the app
right as it manifests the collective
belief of the members of the party you
want them to play a role too right and
so it would effectively restructure
inside of the democracy we have
various uh you know roles and
responsibilities there are ways to do it
but again
i wouldn't advocate for any old liquid
democracy version the devil is in the
details you've got to get them right
otherwise it will have its own
externalities and downsides that are
hard to foresee so
something in the neighborhood is cool
but be very very cautious about the
instantiation that you embrace
john mcwhorter feels that some people
cannot be reasoned with since their
opinions are articles of faith
what line do you draw for engaging what
he calls the elect and other difficult
people
i think it depends
it depends on what kind of faith we're
talking about
well but also just before you begin i
don't you don't
there's no line
right i mean both you and i and this is
part of what our success in the
classroom was
uh engage individuals as they come
right so
it's not going to be a population based
line like or
and by population based i don't mean
demographics but like well if you
believe x y or z then i know you can't
be reasoned with like it's going to be
very hard there will be exceptions to
all exceptions to all such rules
i will say
i've dealt with lots of people who would
describe themselves as people of faith
and i almost never run into anybody who
really
will just uh
refuse to engage a reasoned argument
right you may not persuade them of your
position ultimately but people in
general are interested in having those
discussions and we've been given a sort
of
cartoon of of what faith looks like
and uh it isn't right and it's it's a
destructive cartoon that said you do
often run into people who have a
perverse incentive
who have reverse engineered
the rationale for it and so this is the
distinction i would draw between a
rationale a true explanation and a
rationalization where you make something
rational that isn't
and
in any case what i would say is if you
run into somebody who really
is just simply impervious to reason it's
probably because the incentives make it
impossible for them to contemplate an
alternative right it may be that the
social incentives in their environment
force them to embrace the idea that
there
is a continuum of sexes for example
right that per person may think well
if i engage in argument that says
actually really there are just two sexes
you know who's gonna talk to me none of
my friends are gonna talk to me again so
that's a perverse incentive and it will
result in something that looks like
faith but really what it is is a
calculation of incentives
have you heard of mines.com
like twitter getter gab
but open source code transparent
algorithm this seems like the way to go
um
i have
i like open source as a
underlying technology
i worry about the ownership of all of
these things that even somebody who
starts a platform and says look here are
the rules that make for a really good
platform right we're going to protect
free exchange of ideas etc etc somebody
can set that thing in motion everybody
can sign up for it and then it can go
public and then suddenly it's exposed to
the same perverse incentives as
everything else so
we need to think about how
not only to generate a better platform
but to stabilize a better platform and
we're going to have to because we've
seen what is you know
twitter has become
uh a schoolyard bully
and
yeah that's gonna happen to every
platform that doesn't figure out how to
rule that out from the get-go
ask zach where we're at time-wise hey
zach
it's a little bit hard to say for
various reasons i have no idea
zack says it's a complex question that
time may not be what we think it is you
ask him what he's on yeah
are you doing drugs
we're at 55 minutes
okay
we have time for a few more here um
women are born with all of our eggs
would ovarian toxins be a primary risk
to our fertility should infertility be
seen through a public health lens
so this um
turns out
i think uh that the they weren't that we
aren't born with all of our eggs um but
that that was a slightly
oversimplification
that was a slight oversimplification of
what is actually true
uh
some new information that came out what
in the odds maybe i'm trying to think of
when when um but that it's certainly
true that um
that
we're born with a lot of our eggs
and that the rate of production um slows
down dramatically
with with time
um and that when you're you know when
every week is
that would be terrible every month as
you ovulate um
you're not producing a new you're not
you're not releasing a newly produced
egg you may be releasing an egg that was
actually formed when you were still in
utero inside your mother
um
but
yes um because
uh
we have
all or most of all of our eggs on board
um at any point in our
prepubescent or adult lives that does
mean that toxins that did go into the
ovaries uh could be potentially uh
damaging and have fertility effects that
we might not know for very long
yeah they're less likely to be transient
than for instance if there were toxins
that were targeting sperm which are
produced
basically you know for for the instance
that they are needed so
i did not get the question at first i
think i now get it and i think the key
question is what is the interaction of
sars kov2 with the placenta
right there's some things like for
example with no placenta in the question
but um no but the question is about uh
when you are in utero could you be
affected by a vaccine that goes to
ovaries if your ovaries are forming and
your eggs are being produced
right
while you are in utero i think that's in
the question but i think it's
fascinating so you know
women women pregnant with girl babies
uh may be at greater risk put putting
their children at greater risk actually
than women pregnant with boy babies yeah
which we didn't we wouldn't know for a
very long time but my point is that
hinges on whether or not things cross
the placenta now given that spike
protein seems to shred the blood-brain
barrier
it seems likely to me you know the
blood-brain barrier and the placenta are
not fundamentally different concepts
right
the uh the placenta different i mean
they're i don't even think that they're
from the same
i can't even figure out what embryonic
uh tissue they're from developmentally
right it's not gonna be the same
phylogenetically right
i'm not saying it is i'm saying that the
job that these things do
is to insulate these uh two systems um
with a semi-permeable barrier and that
semi-permeable barrier in the case of
placenta is spectacularly capable in
fact it keeps
an hiv-infected mother from infecting
her offspring offspring are typically
when they are infected infected during
birth where there's blood
um so anyway it's an amazing structure
and what the spike protein does to it is
a question and therefore whether or not
it's going to have implications for a
fetus is a a
a real an important an important issue
indeed
as a conservative libertarian it's not
that there can't ever be a government
solution to the types of problems you
mentioned for us it comes down to scope
primacy oversight and whether better
alternatives exist outside of it
yeah i would want to
drill down on each of those terms and
figure out exactly what it's meant and
then the thing i would point out to
a died in the wool libertarian and of
course we have libertarian leanings but
are not libertarians
the thing i would point out to a died in
the world libertarian is that the
externality question is a profound one
and it is one that is not dealt with at
the level of the individual right
so the question is we must have
something to address it
and strict libertarianism does not seem
to offer that tool
so
what is that tool right
um
anyway it's a worthy discussion for
another time
and then
uh have you heard about using a nicotine
lozenge for smokers for covid
um
i have to heard nothing about this no
okay
uh have you seen the new study
suggesting that omicron jumped from mice
indicating possible animal reservoir
hazards any thoughts
uh
yeah it's on my list of things to go
back to it sounds like a remarkable
uh fact if it is true if it is true it
is probably downstream of the likely
serial passage experiments that probably
took place in wuhan that probably used
humanized mice and therefore would have
made mice a
hospitable host just as it may have made
ferrets
and minks a hospitable host these are
all animals that would likely have been
used in such a context
and so anyway if it escaped into mice we
have to ask why that jump i mean that's
not a small jump from people right
it is a small jump if the laboratory
involved uh peopleized mice you know
so
yeah anyway uh maybe one day we'll find
out about all this stuff um yeah you
know
yeah we probably ought to
now that christian anderson is back on
twitter we probably asked ought to ask
him for an update on the cover-up see
how it's going
um off twitter for a while oh yeah he
was off twitter he was uh he was driven
off twitter by people who kept uh saying
factual stuff to him that he couldn't
respond to because of the twitter did
send christian off twitter uh truth the
irritation of people with facts sent
anderson off twitter
yeah anderson uh was reportedly hiding
under the desk in his office uh until
people forgot the role that he had
played in covering up the lab leak and
apparently he has decided that enough
people have forgotten that he is now
he's now back
well maybe we should find a new desk
okay two more questions
i mean there's a few more i'm not
getting we're not going to get to all of
them
but we got through most of them
let's see
uh is there a reliable way to measure
the durability of one's natural immunity
is there a reliable way to measure the
durability well here's the problem so
there's two ways that you can interpret
that question which is um you know do
you have immunity at the moment from
having been exposed to cold passed
um and there are various questions about
whether or not you know circulating
antibodies and such are
a good measure um but the other the more
the potentially more interesting
question
uh is is there any way to know
you know a month out from having had
coveted whether or not your immunity
will um you know persist forever as
it seems often to do or if
um or not and i don't i don't think we
have an answer to that at all i i don't
think we have a perfect answer but i
think we have a kind of way in first of
all i would say
antibodies are certain to be a terrible
measure
right that this is we have been sold the
idea that antibodies are the end-all and
be-all of immunity by people who just so
happen to be in the business of selling
crappy vaccines that generate a
temporary boost in antibodies so anyway
that's a sales pitch and we should get
over it
the best immunity comes from t cells
which have something antibody like on
their surface but you can't just go in
and measure the t cells in the same way
that you can measure the circulating
antibodies
so antibodies do we have a good measure
no that's the problem is that actually
it's a tricky question so we can measure
antibodies easily and so we choose to
measure it's a it's a tyranny of metrics
thing right
antibodies are easy to measure but they
also as a function of a healthy response
to a pathogen with which you have been
infected
will drop precipitously after that
infection right
because if your immunity has
been housed over in t cell land where it
is best
then the point is those antibodies you
know there's some optimal level and it's
not a high number so you expect antibody
levels to drop
so anyway the point is what you want to
know
is is your durable immunity there and
how permanent is it which is going to be
a function of a couple things one how
good is the memory on the immune system
side and two how rapidly changing is the
pathogen so that the memory is actually
useful
right
so the evolution of a pathogen can cause
a you know robust immune response to be
irrelevant because by the time you get
your next encounter it doesn't look the
same
so
what you want to know
is
across a population we should probably
assume something like a normal
distribution or maybe it's a power law
that would describe
how long people's immunity lasts right
and so if the immunity is not going to
be very long lasting for a given
pathogen and its interaction with the
immune system then you would expect some
people
to get readily reinfected right people
who are on the low end of that
distribution they should be very
vulnerable to a second infection
to the extent that you have
few documented cases of anybody getting
a second
infection then that suggests it's likely
to be very long-lived because that tail
of the distribution is all are also very
well protected so that's not a perfect
proxy but that's how i would look at it
complex systems wise well i mean there's
also the question of how distantly
related is the virus that you are now
exposed to from the virus that you have
immunity to
so if you know if omicron is so
different from delta
uh that
uh
you know the anecdotal reports that we
hear of people who were sick last summer
and then again sick a month ago
are true um that you know that is
consistent with actually you won't get
delta again
but um but omicron might you know put
forth a new form um that you could be
susceptible to because it's different
enough from the one that you now have
natural immunity to yeah i mean i think
that's a different way of saying the
same thing about the rate of evolution
of the
pathogen the basic point is
immunity depends on similarity
between right the thing that you became
immune to and the thing that you
encounter and a rate of change that is
sufficient will outstrip that at some
point
precisely yeah
okay uh one last question
why didn't birds just evolve back into
dinosaurs
they did and they always are
all moments of every day i mean they
never stop being dinosaurs is the thing
right they
wow you've picked as a last question one
that then you know leads to an hour-long
lecture but
the fact is
you are a member of every clade
to which
you have
uh what to which you once belonged to
which you once belonged yes you never
exit one of the you know penguins don't
stop being birds because they stopped
flying
so let's just let's just do this uh
precisely
once a meat-eater not always a
meat-eater right like meat-eaters can
become fruit eaters and
uh that doesn't mean that they're still
meat-eaters at heart we can actually
change functionally ecologically into
something different you don't retain all
of the ecological things all of your
ancestors were all the functional things
all of your ancestors were yeah but
phylogenetically in terms of
your history and our naming of the
groups uh of that history you know once
an animal always an animal
once once a vertebrate always a
vertebrate once a tetrapod always a
tetrapod even if you go and lose your
limbs and become a snake you're still a
tetrapod four-legged tetrapod even
though you don't have the four legs that
are the reason for the name of the thing
once a mammal always a mammal even if
some mammal evolves it doesn't have
mammary glands and so it doesn't have
the eponymous trait but it's still a
member of the group so dinosaurs evolved
and out of them emerged birds so birds
are still dinosaurs even though we don't
think of them as such
i do but um
the uh
so
contained in that is the example that
you need to keep in mind so what
heather's saying is you've got
functional descriptions like something
is warm-blooded or carnivorous and then
you've got phylogenetic uh distinction
something is a marsupial uh or an animal
you never leave
a phylogenetic group right they are
nested sets completely nested one within
another
so for the example of tetrapods
tetrapods sounds like it is a
description of a four-legged animal
right but it is a phylogenetic
description of a group that was
initially four-legged and in which most
of the members still are they don't have
to be but they are but
snakes are in the tetrapods even though
they have no limbs because they are
historically there they are not however
quadrupeds quadruped means has four legs
right tetrapod means a functional
distinction whereas tetrapod is a
phylogenic distinction there's no way to
know that from the word right you have
to be clued in and you know have some
biology background but
uh the the historical distinction you
don't leave a historical group that you
belong to because that time has passed
like you're in it you're in it forever
regardless of whether or not you still
look like any of the other members of
the group right and so anyway i wrote an
essay years ago uh on being a fish and
the basic point is look you are a fish
in fact half of fish are tetrapods
right
because the group fish if fish means
something that flops around in the water
then
it's not what we all think because then
whales are fish right whales are fish by
virtue of them being flopping around in
the water rather than them having an
ancestral uh membership in the group um
what else the web party has definitely
come after you
they totally are well flop
yeah well
all right
wales i love you i didn't mean anything
via i spoke carelessly but uh
so in any case um
birds are dinosaurs every bit as much as
a tyrannosaurus rex is a dinosaur or a
brontosaurus right they are full-fledged
dinosaurs and um
isn't it wouldn't you rather live in a
world in which we just simply admit that
that's true rather than a world in which
we pretend that it's somehow not um it's
cool we've got lots of dinosaurs and you
can go to the park and feed them if you
like um it's it's a it's an awesome fact
of being a human on earth even now
all right
i think that's it i think we did it i
think i think we did it um
yeah we will be back next week um in the
room that brett is currently inhabiting
uh rather than in this room where i've
i've raised the the blinds and you can
see the forest behind me so
um actually this raises an interesting
question let's suppose that i have
caught omicron which is not unlikely
given that we're in the same house
as of next week
and then i might have to isolate even
though that makes no sense that the
cdc's advice would still say
that uh
i have to isolate even though the people
who might be infected have already been
infected potentially really you really
don't want me to say on air what i'm
thinking right now
about the cdc oh um yeah
um
i hear you
all right so let's um
i encourage you um i i i did explore
some of my thoughts not about the cdc so
much but about some of this um in in my
sub stack the last couple of weeks and i
may rant a bit um this upcoming week as
well so i encourage those of you who are
looking for that sort of thing to go to
naturalselections.substance.com
um and all the other places you know
uh patreons find our book
brett's active on twitter raising hell
not getting not getting banned
um
all
all the stuff
so anything else to say
no
i think we're there
okay
till next week then be good to the ones
you love
eat good food and get outside stand up
everyone see you later
[Music]
you